[Music]
on this monday night new urgency in the
climate emergency it's one minute to
midnight on that doomsday clock and we
need
to act now the push for less talk and
actual action as critics take aim at
canada's goals if you have a problem in
your organization you better deal with
it the nhl's top boss breaks his silence
on sexual abuse in the league we could
not be more sorry family feud the
roger's power struggle goes to bc's
supreme court and an unbreakable bond
with her daughter every time i turn my
head she's beside me this year's silver
cross mother and a village honor a
fallen soldier
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight robin gill enough of
treating nature like a toilet
enough of burning and drilling and
mining our way deeper
we are digging our own graves
1.5
is what we need to survive
2 degrees
yes
sg is a death sentence
you wield the weapons that can save us
or sell us out
those are the stark warnings to act now
or pay the price at the u.n climate
conference in glasgow scotland
good evening and thank you for joining
us the pressure is on world leaders
gathering at cop26 over the next two
weeks they must make a serious
commitment to reduce harmful greenhouse
gas emissions in an effort to limit
global warming and the accelerating
effects of human-caused climate change
but the clock is ticking and the
temperatures are rising the six years
since the paris agreement was reached
have been the hottest on record and a
new report released from the un's
weather agency highlights that our
planet is changing before our eyes and
how extreme weather events are the new
norm our crystal gomencing reports from
glasgow tonight on the demands for
meaningful action over empty promises
inside cope they're just politicians and
people in power pretending to take our
future seriously riled up and
understandably angry greta toonberg
already has a number of environmental
summits under her belt and despite all
of the earnest nodding and political
pledges she's seen and heard the climate
keeps warming 2021 is on track to rank
between the fifth and seventh warmest
year on record according to the un's
world meteorological organization they
will judge us with bitterness and with a
resentment that eclipses any of the
climate activists of today and they will
be right british prime minister boris
johnson is the leader of the host nation
but at cop26 he could also be the
conservative voice to pull more climate
skeptical tories to the table
this summit is the first gathering since
the paris climate agreement if that was
about establishing a vision glasgow is
supposed to be about execution what have
nations done and how will they do more
to up their commitments promises that
can have real impacts positive or
negative the arctic sea ice is our air
conditioner canadian researcher
stephanie peck recently spent time out
on a tundra buggy in the normally frigid
manitoba north watching polar bears and
sharing her research she says a degree
or two could reduce polar bear breeding
abilities we also know that sea ice
reflects back the heat from the sun so
when we are shrinking that sea ice we're
now absorbing more of that heat into the
oceans
so again it's all connected and i think
saving the bears is really saving
ourselves for awkward laughter and
underlying anxiety this is a message the
world still isn't hearing canada is
warming on average twice as quickly as
the rest of the world
and in our north
it's three times quicker
carbon taxes and offsetting plans will
be highlighted at cop26 along with the
need for richer nations to help poorer
ones battle the effects of climate
change and reduce their reliance on
fossil fuels find practical ways of
overcoming differences
so we can all get down to work together
to rescue this precious planet
scientists have been emphatic leading up
to this summit that the planet is fast
approaching a point of no return
already people around the world are
experiencing first hand the effects of
climate change in the face of more
extreme weather events and adaptation
this summit is seen as the last
meaningful opportunity for the world to
act together
crystal gomencing global news
glasgow
prime minister justin trudeau says his
government will take the absolutely
necessary step to cap this country's oil
and gas emissions to meet the 2050 net
zero target our michael couture is
traveling with the prime minister at cop
26 mike what is trudeau's main message
at the climate conference
well robin prime minister justin trudeau
came to cop 26 sounding the alarm on the
environmental emergency and he did it
with a very real and recent example of
how climate change has already changed
canada there was a town called lytton
i say was
because on june 30th
it burned to the ground the story of
canada's record summer heat and its
devastating impacts got delegates
attention hoping to prove canada is
pulling its weight trudeau also
presented an election promise he's
pledging will become government policy
we'll cap
oil and gas sector emissions today
and ensure they decrease tomorrow at a
pace and scale needed to reach net zero
by 2050. that's the goal but the
government still needs the roadmap to
get there it's why the minister of
natural resources and the minister of
environment sent this letter to the
canadian net zero advisory board asking
for advice on quote the development of
quantitative
five-year targets i'm the first one to
say that we need to do more and my
government and the prime minister said
we we need to do more which is why we
we've announced this cap on on oil and
gas emissions which is why we've
committed to phasing out fossil fuel
subsidies two years earlier than all of
our g20 partners we saw nothing new so
of course this lacked ambition
environmental advocates at this summit
weren't impressed by trudeau's
presentation and plan unfortunately the
solution he came up with focused on
emissions and not production and what
that allows is for oil and gas companies
to continue to put forward false
solutions our missions today are the
same pretty much as they were in 2005. i
think the world has reason to feel
suspicious of canada when it says we're
going to do more we're going to do
better this international conference is
only just underway and while leaders
statements do set the tone climate
advocates we've spoken to hope ambition
will increase over the next two weeks to
meet the urgency of the moment
robin michael couture with our team
coverage in glasgow scotland
mike mentioned the record temperatures
in bc were a big part of the prime
minister's address in glasgow a new
figures from bc's corner service show
the true toll of that disaster between
june 18th and august 12th nearly 600
people died from the extreme heat
526 of those deaths happened during the
heat dome in late june a staggering 231
people died in a single day on june 29th
with climate talks underway there's a
lot at stake for alberta home to
canada's oil and gas sector premier
jason kenney is not attending the summit
though he did mark its start today by
announcing 176 million dollars in
provincial and federal funds for 16
projects the province says these
projects will cut nearly 7 million tons
of emissions by 2030.
alberta is home to some of the most
enterprising and entrepreneurs in the
world who recognize that innovation
the environment and economic prosperity
go hand in hand
to reach canada's climate goals a lot
more will have to happen in the months
and years ahead heather york's west
looks at whether alberta's oil and gas
sector is ready for change
researchers in this calgary lab are
trying to innovate for the road ahead
working to turn alberta bitumen into
carbon fiber a construction material
stronger and lighter than steel we think
this is a truly transformational
opportunity
we're looking to divert
a lot of bitumen from being combusted as
it is today and stand up entirely new
industries
as the world moves away from fossil
fuels as an energy source the province
will need to diversify but right now
alberta's oil and gas industry is
booming once again although the oil
sands have worked to reduce the amount
of emissions produced per barrel after a
drop in production in 2020 the sector
has produced more oil in 2021 than ever
before and that means emissions are
rising too we in the oil sense know that
we are a huge part of that challenge we
uh we are responsible oil sands not even
the whole oil industry
responsible for a full 10 percent of
canada's emissions we therefore have to
be a really big part of this solution
canada's major oil producers have
proposed a plan that would see
production reach net zero emissions by
2050 a 75 billion dollar investment in
carbon capture and storage the industry
hopes the federal government will help
fund i just think the opportunity here
we address our emission side we should
be the globally preferred source of that
oil which would be
so good from not only an environmental
perspective but also from a canadian
perspective while hull findlay a former
liberal member of parliament expects
global demand for oil to grow through
2050 not all forecasters agree under
existing climate policies the
international energy agency expects
demand for canadian oil will begin
dropping by 2030. so we need to be
planning
for that future as well to be planning
for new sources of growth
in the face of risks to old sources of
growth that's that's not partisanship
that's not ideology that is sensible
planning because big changes will be
coming whether this global energy shift
is still decades away or coming at the
end of this one heather urex west global
news calgary
thousands of non-emergency medical
appointments and procedures across
newfoundland and labrador have been
canceled after a suspected cyber attack
on the province's health care system
this led to progressive failure of
what's been described to me as the the
brain of the data center
and a loss of functionality in systems
across the regional health authorities
the disruption was first detected
saturday the province's eastern health
region was hardest hit losing everything
from email to diagnostic images and lab
results
nhl commissioner gary bettman has
publicly apologized to kyle beach for
what the former chicago blackhawks
prospect had been through beech says he
was sexually assaulted by an assistant
coach in 2010
accusations he says were ignored and
covered up mike drillet reports
this certainly has been
a disturbing and difficult week for all
of us nhl commissioner gary bettman made
no excuses for the chicago blackhawks
covering up accusations of sexual
assault a decade ago was wrong i was
horrified
it was emotional
i was
distressed
a week after the damning report
implicating chicago management in
suppressing brad aldrich's alleged
assault on kyle beach bettman was
careful in his wording supportive of
beach yet careful in answering any
questions of a legal nature as soon as
you have the lawsuit it becomes
culpability and it becomes damages and
that's where it gets trickier for all
parties involved including the plate up
it's definitely a very much of a stain
on the national hockey league
particularly the chicago blackhawks i
mean it's it's it it it sort of wafts
over all the team last week blackhawks
ownership said it was looking to settle
a pair of lawsuits against them around
the same time chicago's lawyers moved to
dismiss both cases while the nhl has
offered beech and his family
psychological services
bettman wouldn't commit to helping the
teenager aldrich has already been
convicted of assaulting after the
blackhawks recommendation helped him
secure a high school coaching job
i would have to know more about that
circumstance lawyer greg glooly was
himself a victim of sexual assault whose
story was unavoidable in the hockey
world a decade ago
i'm disappointed because
this in 2010 happened just
over a month after i came forward with
my story about graham james that the
blackhawks not only suppressed the story
but gave aldrich a letter of
recommendation for his next job is
inexcusable but he believes the same
thing wouldn't happen today am i
optimistic yes because i don't believe
that in 2021 joel quenville would be
allowed to leave the meeting
directing people not to look after
things i believe we live in a different
world things are getting better the nhl
does have a rule compelling teams to
inform the league whenever something
like this happens in december chicago
did do exactly that but they didn't
reveal the merits of the case mike
drolie global news toronto
from the board room to the courtroom
coming up the fight for rogers winds up
before bc judge
[Music]
the roger sega is playing out in a bc
courtroom today the family is battling
for control of canada's largest wireless
company it's a real-life succession
cliffhanger and gaviola is following all
the twists and turns and what is the
latest on this legal challenge well the
very latest is that this family feud is
moving from the court of public opinion
into an actual courtroom before bc's top
court so ahead of this we've had
literally hundreds of documents filed by
various members of the family
and the battle lines have been drawn
robin in the one camp you have edward
rogers the only son of late founder ted
rogers and on the other side the other
camp you have rogers corporation which
includes edward's mother and his two
sisters and what came to light is edward
rogers attempt to unseat the current ceo
of rogers joe natalie when that came to
light edward was subsequently fired from
his position on the corporate board but
he remains chair of the family trust
which holds the lion's share of voting
power he used that position to appoint a
new board with some allies to tilt the
balance of power in his favor his mother
and his sisters say this other board is
illegitimate it's going to be up to bc
supreme court to decide who's in the
right legally i've been speaking to
corporate governance experts legal
experts they say it's just a matter of
time though before edward prevails
i'm not sure how they're going to uh
win i mean they may get it delayed
saying okay you did it wrong
procedurally mr rogers you should have
done it not by a private note you should
have gone to a formal shareholder
meeting but that doesn't diminish or
remove his authority
to vote those shares if i was a betting
person i think edward is going to win in
court today but what happens after that
is is up for debate
so anne where does this go from here
well regardless of what's decided by
bc's top court keep in mind both sides
have deep pockets and they have the
ability to drag this out and appeal all
of this is happening while regulators
decide whether or not to green light the
rogers take over that 26 billion dollar
deal of shaw which would be its biggest
acquisition ever perhaps it's most
important robin all right and gaviola in
toronto
still ahead why tens of thousands were
locked down in the happiest place on
earth
today there were tears of joy at
airports in australia after more than 18
months the country has finally relaxed
its international border restrictions
for now travel is limited to fully
vaccinated australian citizens permanent
residents and their immediate families
international tourists could be allowed
sometime next year
in china a single case of kova 19 has
shut down shanghai disneyland according
to chinese state media officials sealed
off the theme park yesterday after
learning a woman in the area had tested
positive public health teams entered the
park in full hazmat suits and the nearly
34 thousand people inside had to be
tested before leaving
officials say all tests came back
negative
the world has hit yet another grim
milestone in the pandemic the number of
people killed by the virus has now
officially surpassed 5 million and those
are just the confirmed deaths experts
say the true number is likely much
higher the united states has recorded
the most deaths of any country more than
740 thousand brazil is second hardest
hit with more than 600 000 deaths
up next how this year's silvercross
mother is honoring her daughter's
sacrifice
every year the royal canadian legion
picks a silver cross mother on
remembrance day she lays a wreath on
behalf of all mothers who lost a son or
daughter in military service it's an
immense honor but one no parent wants a
woman from quebec is this year's silver
cross mother her daughter corporal karen
black was only 21 years old when she was
killed in afghanistan mike armstrong has
her story
the small village of les meschen quebec
is tucked away on the south shore of the
saint lawrence river it is a world away
from afghanistan but not so far that in
april of 2009
they couldn't hear the bagpipes
[Applause]
when corporal kerenble was carried up
the ramp by her brothers and sisters in
arms in kandahar her mother says the
village changed
she says the war seemed very close to
everyone in les misery it was no longer
just something on tv
jose simal still lives on the banks of a
small creek where she raised her two
children her son billy was just 14 when
kevin was killed walk around her home
and there are memories of karen in every
direction a photo is a member of the
12th armored regiment a picture in
civilian clothes
and the one she was given on this day by
the governor general when karen's body
arrived back in canada at trenton
it hangs in the kitchen
every time i turn my head she's beside
me sima says she is everywhere in my
house
corporal karen blair was killed april 13
2009. she was driving a coyote an
armored vehicle part of the patrol just
meant to show canadian forces were
present they were north of kandahar when
they hit an ied play was killed four men
were injured and everyone involved was
affected they'd been in afghanistan
barely two weeks
simal says every year around november 11
men and women who were with karen come
to visit some are still serving some
have left the military but it's a time
when they want to be together
now simar won't be home this remembrance
day she'll be serving as the silver
cross mother in ottawa she's been asked
before but chose to spend the day with
keren's friends
the only one she missed was in 2010 when
simal went to afghanistan herself on a
next of kin visit
small says she wanted to breathe the
same air where karen took her last
breath and to see the country she was
trying to help
now it has been difficult over the last
few months watching what's happened in
afghanistan the taliban again taking
control of the country small says she
focuses on what was accomplished how a
generation of women went to school and
were educated
and how some are pushing back
canada she says made a difference
karen didn't die for
nothing now her daughter knew every
corner of the village but there have
been some changes there's a street named
corporal kerenble
and a monument that went up just a
couple of years after she was
lost says she sees her daughter every
day while she used to babysit children
in the village she now watches over
everyone
mike armstrong global news les meschens
quebec
a beautiful story mike global news will
have live coverage of the remembrance
day ceremony in ottawa you can watch it
at 10 30 a.m eastern 7 30 pacific we'll
also be streaming the special on our
website
globalnews.ca
and that is global national for this
monday night i'm robin gill tonight your
canada is this bear cub hanging out in
pork aquitlam bc we'd love to see your
corner of the country so please keep
sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]